kirk cousins i did commit i made the
commitment you win the super bowl he's
the mvp i get the tattoo and it prompted
some to actually root for the outcome
where he would be the super bowl mvp but
the vikings lose the game oh well that's
not the ultimate trifecta for people who
want to see you get your your feathers
ruffled yeah but uh i i stand by it i
stand by it and i'm i'm willing to
extend the commitment into twenty one
kirk joints yeah well i know you are
because you're a die hard vikings fan as
much as you wanna say yes you are you
wouldn't get a tattoo of any other team
i know that that's your guy but it is
going to be fun and i know kirk cousins
yeah he's uh taken a ver some verbal
abuse really from both of us mainly you
but he's also i think very
real in recognizing the big picture of
things too and then got you back with
the you know crack cancer thing this
summer
a lot of eggs where you and you know not
only got you but that extent ended up
extending to me thank you mike yeah and
your family and all your close friends
they really seemed to enjoy throwing
eggs on your head too that was a fun fun
video to watch yeah and it was a lot of
eggs it was a whole lot it was
disgusting yeah weekend we may talk
about that a little bit more i know that
you just had like one or two eggs but it
completely disgusted you but yeah
hopefully he has not brought any eggs oh
he's coming
this is the best segment ever in pft
history here he is welcome back
good to see you have a seat grab a
microphone good to see you doing all
right come on jump in let's let's just
just rag on florio or this whole segment
okay it's from the moment that they said
you're gonna be joining us he will not
let me hear the end i can't wait i'm
going to get him all fired up he's going
to beat you up before he leaves kirk
welcome back how are you thank you
appreciate it good to see you thank you
for being such a stand-up citizen and
guy for coming here
and dealing with this that's all good
and it was an awesome move by you to
throw the crack cancer thing on to him
this this last year i just wanted to see
yeah yeah and it worked i took like 20
eggs i told i they destroyed me did you
see i ever seen the video you did it's
outstanding good oh there it is i mean
it is disgusting it really
is but then he just kept going then he
got to do it too and it was just like
one or two and i think you were sick for
a week i was sick for a week
dogs licked it up off the ground and
they like started throwing up later that
day too that was a fun semester i love
it but kirk is great to talk to you look
we
we
we're candid in our views sure and when
you play well
we're the first ones to say so and there
were times where
far more often than not this year it was
great i mean you had a great great
season and we congratulate you on that
it was a special year yeah i was happy
to uh you know get 10 wins get in the
playoffs uh win a playoff game
there's a lot to be encouraged about
certainly when you're not playing this
weekend you're disappointed most teams
are
but looking back you feel like you know
there's a lot to be encouraged about now
as we looked at 2020 and uh um you know
got a lot of good players on that team
yeah you definitely do i mean the first
thing i got to ask you you know because
i you know i got to talk sense into him
every now and then but what was the
turning point to you this year because
everybody i think looks at it me
especially like thielen kind of calling
you out to a degree right which i still
don't like that he did that to you all
right but either way is that the turning
point
well people like to look at that you
know for me i really played the same way
all the way through i just felt like
things started to turn a little bit yeah
um you know i felt like we were running
the ball well we had a good football
team it was just a matter of time we
were two and two
and um
and then you know next i think we went
eight and two over the next ten games
and that that certainly made a huge
difference in the tenor of the season
but as far as just the way i approached
it the way i played i never really
adjusted or changed anything i just
think that uh we were able to find some
continuity as an offense and it was
another year of a new system right once
we kind of hit our stride we were able
to kind of take off and not look back we
talked to staphon about this yesterday
kirk the throw that you made adam thiel
on the 43 yarder in overtime
best throw your life arguably close to
it under the circumstances what with
what was writing on it and then the next
play the snap down at your hip you got
to grab it you got to get rid of it
quickly i mean those two plays the kind
of thing that maybe elevates a team
elevates a player how much of what
happened in that game setting aside the
next week what happens in that game that
carries over into 2020 well i think when
you can win a playoff game especially on
the road it does something for your
confidence for your team's belief
certainly the next week against san fran
was tough and we saw that hey there's
another mountain to climb here that we
weren't ready to climb yet um if
anything maybe that loss to san fran is
what galvanizes us going into otas and
training camp knowing that we've got
some work to do you can't rest on any
laurels you know we have we have a place
to go that we proved when we weren't
ready to go yet so um we'll take a lot
from both but there's certainly an
encouragement winning a playoff game
saying hey we can do this i mean that's
exactly what happened to the bears in
84. we talked about that a few weeks ago
49ers the bears got shut out by the
49ers in the championship game in 84 and
they became determined after that this
is this is the mountain that we have to
climb and they became the 85 bears the
next year yeah you always look back at
other teams when we were the sixth seed
i was looking okay what other six seeds
have done this you thought of the 2010
packers right on the run they made and
so you're always kind of looking at
what's the precedent for this who's done
in the past and you kind of gain
encouragement from that so if we have
the 85 bear defense we might have a shot
yeah right you might be able to get me a
quarterback if that happens i've got
real estate reserved on my left arm we
played it before you came out here
mvp getting the tattoo i don't know if
you were aware of that he was gonna get
attacked i mean i i went in full you
know fledged kirk cousins was that
unique to this past season or no i'm
willing to extend it i'm willing to
extend it for another year it's gonna be
fun to kind of follow yeah as we go here
come on big guy as if there weren't
enough reasons to get to uh oh yeah
that's right
it's there yes absolutely that's what
happens i will do it and uh you lost
your mind when i told him about it but
i've i told kyle rudolph about it during
the season he got a kick out oh dear god
dear god dear god please let the vikings
win the super bowl please what do you
need to do tangibly i mean
you know
get to work and and check the boxes yeah
but give me something russell wilson
talked earlier about what the seahawks
need to get to the next level what do
you think the vikings need to push
through to the point where you're
playing in this game well it'll be key
because there's so much turnover every
year to whoever comes in new you know we
got a new coordinator we've got
thankfully it's someone who's already
been within our system so we're not
starting over but uh as we draft as new
free agents come in as other players
have to move on just making sure
everybody gets on the same page as
quickly as possible and we build this
thing through april may and june so that
we're not still figuring it out in
september and october like to some
degree we may have been last year you
know we can't afford to have that and
right those two losses early you end up
looking back and you say man is that the
difference between the sixth seed and
the two students yeah right
right when you go on the road and get
beat by san fran you start to realize
the importance of a one or a two seat if
you can get it so just getting everybody
on the same page and then i'll always
look at my game in a loss like san
francisco of what i can do better and
certainly i think you know playing off
schedule and being able to make some
plays when things aren't there is
something i'm going to try to work on
you know as we go through this off
season yep all right we're going to play
a little game let's do it that's the
game well who said this we're gonna i
want him to get guess which one of us
said this this quote let's do it do you
have it no i got it you do okay this
conflicts with everything i've said most
of the year about kirk cousins but i
don't think the gap right now between
kirk cousins and patrick mahomes is as
broad as people would think it is who
said that mr sims
i'm gonna guess sims
yeah you would think right logic and i
root for you but actually crazy man here
said it i did say i believed it and you
i believe that at the time you believed
that i almost fell off my chair on real
tv when he said it i couldn't believe it
you know here's the thing and i paid
very close attention to the things you
said publicly about the criticism and
the issues that came up after the bears
game you did take that you know guys say
all the time oh we don't listen to any
of the noise you took the noise and you
used that
i believe to to
motivate yourself to a higher level and
i mean it carried you through the whole
year is that is that an accurate
assessment the criticism and all the
stuff after that bears game became like
the fuse for you that that pushed you to
what we saw yeah what was interesting
was uh i don't go and read it and yet
it's impossible to avoid because you're
being asked about it at your press deal
on wednesday and so you understand
there's something out there and all that
you can piece it together um yeah i do
think in some ways even going back to
you like that game that any time i've
kind of been doubted and attacked for
whatever reason i've played better don't
really know why i feel like i'm going
about my business the same way but the
results would say that i've played
better and um who knows maybe it just
helps me find that extra fire i don't i
don't really know we asked stefan
yesterday important question because the
narrative with the vikings is if the run
game's there the pass game will be there
but if the run game's not there the past
game may not be there how do you change
that so you don't need to have dalvin
cook or alexander madison ripping off
those big gains to soften up the defense
for the pass
well you know sometimes it's truly how
your offensive team is built too yeah
you know if you're gonna if you're gonna
commit to that then you're gonna commit
to that you know i've played on teams
that did not commit to the run and we
were very effective throwing the ball
through for almost 5 000 yards in 2016
but at the same time we weren't a
running football team yeah so some of it
is you know what's your identity going
to be and if that's what you're going to
lean on it you know it needs to be there
too right um but you know we'll we'll go
back to this off season and work with
gary and the staff and look at how we
can be more effective because there's
going to come games where you're just
not going to be able to run it and that
was kind of what adam's comments were
after week four was yeah the gate the
day's going to come where you can't run
it right and and what now right and uh
and i think that'll certainly be a
challenge we're going to try to answer
you know as we go through this off
season and next year your teammates love
you that was one of the coolest moments
i just want to say that after you the
new orleans saints i mean when you said
you like that and you're i mean it
really i think it gave us chills i mean
we laughed about it all week it was one
of the great clips of the year i do want
to ask you this you played both of these
teams in the super bowl yeah come on
give me a little scouting report what
jumps out to you about both teams what
was interesting was when we played the
chiefs patrick was out and frank clark
was out right uh chris jones was the
real deal he had a big impact right
after we played them because we felt
like their defense statistically going
into our game was not that dominant
we felt like they were very good defense
when we played them even without frank
clark right and then statistically the
rest of the year they were actually
elite so i'm not quite sure what
happened but we felt that elite defense
was was was more of what we got than the
one that had been going on the first
half of the season right um but not
seeing the homes you wonder how much did
that change the field of that game and
then i lost to him uh late in the game
and then uh sam france certainly you
know kind of beat the brakes office so
yeah especially in the second half so um
you feel like both teams deserve to get
there yeah you know and you usually do
and you go through the playoffs and beat
good teams um that's what's gonna make
it so fun but uh one's gonna be ground
and pound it would seem the other one's
gonna be you know all kinds of places in
the air and right we'll see how it plays
out that d line in san fran like as
advertised is it the best you saw this
year yeah i think when you can rotate
people in reminds me of the eagles
d-line when they won it all right you
had five or six recognizable names and
pass rushers so that they were rotating
them in so they're always fresh
and you're not asking the same guy to
rush the passer with everything he's got
over and over and over again so i think
their depth
not only
is great for having great players but
enables them to be at their best more
often because they're not fatigued right
kirk joins us today
on behalf of sleep number this is your
chance to give us the big pitch so if
y'all go out and buy a sleep number bed
well we got the sleep number set up over
there awesome
you know i've got a sleep number bed in
minnesota and everywhere else we go and
uh it's been a game changer for me i've
had it for two years now and um you know
i want to play as long as the tom
brady's the drew brees is you know eli
manning just retired but what a career
he had and with over 200 starts and you
want to get there and i do think that
quality sleep and quantity sleep is so
important it's huge to the recovery and
being able to get there so it's a
commitment of mine i really believe in
it and um i'm thrilled that sleep number
is willing to partner and and help me
get there what time you like what time
you've gone to bed every night on your
side so i'm going to bed early i started
this probably about when i was on my
2015 when i when i started to be the
starter more often
um
i was going to bed about nine o'clock
yeah and then getting up about six so
getting about nine hours a night is what
i try to do yeah good for you i i gotta
ask people we gotta ask him about
shanahan i mean shanahan thought he was
gonna bring you to the 49ers right i
mean we know that that's what he thought
you know give us give us your thought
what makes kyle so awesome through kirk
cousins eyes
well it's i remember my uh rookie year
um
week one we're at the saints and and uh
we got a rookie quarterback and i'm
backing him up as a rookie quarterback
and we put up i think it was 40-some
points right and we had a new number one
receiver in pierre garcon a new number
two and josh morgan a rookie running
back and alfred morris and they put up
40 points right and i remember calling
my dad after the game saying
wow i mean what kyle shanahan did as a
game planner and play caller today was
unbelievable and so i knew early this
guy's pretty special yeah um it's not
any one thing you know i think it's
evolved through the years you see the
jet sweep motions more this year than
you have in past years but i just think
he takes so much pride in it and grinds
on it right it's the most important
thing in his life in a lot of ways that
he studies it and knows what to call
week in and week out and uh certainly
gets that from his dad and and uh uh has
done a phenomenal job and not only in
the play calling but in talent
evaluation in terms of who he's drafted
who brings him in free agency he's on
top of it yeah well hey kirk we
appreciate you very much we appreciate
you for being a good support and
understanding yeah
coach dungey that you saw the guy with
the t-shirt that says just one in my
lifetime
i got that shirt so i love it that's why
that's why we do what we do and i wish
you the best in 2020
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports